[Music]
let's go to alicia gosh this is the
second show in a row with someone from
oklahoma what's up alicia
hello how are you good how are we doing
i'm doing pretty good hey the last
person i talked to from oklahoma did a
good job so i trust you i trust you okay
i'll try
too much breath alright so what's up
what's up
okay um so i have been in the military
for seven years
my fiance has been in for four and we're
kind of at this point where i'm trying
to to decide if i should stay in the
military for another year and a half or
um
and get out or should i
like continue on and be separated for
from him for like
potentially two plus years
does that make sense yeah totally so
y'all are
both in the service and you're getting
stationed
on opposite ends of the planet yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah so what do you want to do
um
i
i love the military um like i said i've
been in for seven years i feel like it's
i think the only
thing i'm good at or maybe i've i've
done it like my
adult life so
i'm just very comfortable here now there
you go you just you saved yourself like
seven months of counseling just there
you're good at a million things but
you're comfortable okay cool
yes i'm comfortable and so
i think it's like the unknown of getting
out but i also want to be with him
and
i don't want to be like geographically
separated for over two years
right
so the word that keeps coming to mind is
unknown all across the board here
and you have to decide which unknown do
you want do you want unknown of this boy
i'm just kidding that's awesome i'm glad
you found somebody do you want unknown
of
making a leap into what could be the
rest of your life relationship
and the unknown of not being in the
military or do you want the safety of i
know what's going to happen monday the
monday 11 years from now i know it's
going to happen
oh
that's so tough
really
well
i like the safety i really like the
safety and that's why i like him because
i feel really safe around him yeah but
you're not safe if he's
17 hours away
right yeah
is
do you feel safe around him or is the
idea of him safe
uh i feel safe around him okay because
sometimes people pack up and move across
the country because the idea of somebody
else the significant other felt good
but when i got next to them they it
wasn't them it was the idea of them in
the reality of them the unknown of them
was more
was heavier than
the
illusion i had earlier right but you're
telling me that no when i'm in this like
this
this guy may be it
yes yes can i ask you another weird
question yeah yes go for it um because
you've had a you've had a front row seat
to this is there any trepidation are you
nervous about being a military wife
yes
it's just
i don't know i
we kind of have
certain perspectives of them um
good and bad and i just don't want to be
on the other side of it that was the
nicest we kind of have certain
perspectives of them they're so good
like they're this uh this like just
group of gremlins running around yeah
man their life is so hard right and but
yes you've been on this side of the
fence for seven years looking through
the little hole in the fence being like
ugh
and now you're like oh no i'm gonna be
one of them
yeah
so have you sat down and had an honest
conversation about
with
a military wife about that world that
life
um
no actually
you should probably do that
seems like a good idea
okay do you think
yeah it seems like you're you're
stepping into the unknown and what's
cool about uh what's
a good way to step into the unknown is
with data
okay and the best way to get data is to
sit down and be like hey i've talked
crap about you all for a long time
what's your life actually like
and you may have to have some egg on
your face and be like oh my gosh chelsea
life is not what i thought even though
we just thought you all got together and
taught crap other people in service you
know just complained about
it's actually pretty hard you know what
i mean you'll have to you'll have to
just kind of be like i'm sorry about
that by the way as a guy who's had egg
on his face pretty much every day
throughout his life it's cool it's all
right you just say i'm sorry and then
you do better next time
okay do you want to do that do you like
this guy
i do
i do
what are you going to do when you get
out of the military
i don't know that's why i don't know i
you have something so long i mean i do
um
i would like to i would like to be a
police officer so that was like my
backup plan if i
didn't make the military a career
but
i know that can be equally as
challenging
yeah that's a whole other adventure
um i wouldn't compare challenge but
that's a totally new adventure that
you'd probably be incredible at and do
both in and is super flexible right
precincts all over the country are
hiring police officers
so here's i'm gonna tell you i'm not
gonna tell you what to do i don't have
that i don't i don't have permission to
speak into that and be like i think you
should do this with this i don't know
you i don't know him i don't know your
situation
i think you have a choice between
do i want the unknown do i want a new
adventure and i don't know what's behind
door number four i think i do
or do i want comfort and
routine
and i'm willing to forego a really great
relationship i'm ready to forego a brand
new career
for safety and comfort and i'm not going
to judge you either way i know how i've
chosen to live in various moments of my
history
but my life's different than yours so
what are you gonna do
i think i'm gonna get out in a year and
a
half
when you just said that out loud how
does it feel
um
terrifying
pretty terrifying but uh
relaxing at the same time yeah
i think it's good to i guess make a
decision
if you get out
and you go be a police officer and y'all
break up can you go back in
uh
yes but i think there's there would be
like a um
i think they give you a minimum of like
a certain amount of time that you can't
you have to wait so many months before
you can get back in gotcha i'm just
wondering if what that looks like
um
i'm gonna do two things i'm going to
send you a copy of my friend ken
coleman's paycheck to purpose book just
teach you like here what do i want to do
with my life and what does purpose look
like
and it's a bestseller it's a good book
and i'll just send it to you for free
okay
and um how long have you been with this
dude
um since 2020
oh you all are covet lovers
yeah it's gonna say coven daters but
you're covered lovers you're about to
get out of the military for this dude
so is this like is this you see a runway
here for y'all
uh
yes so we want to
like elope later this year
come down to nashville we'll do it here
on on campus at ramsey solutions do
that okay i'm sure that will go well
[Laughter]
though do what
he loves dave so come on all right so
here's i'm gonna give y'all for your
about to be engaged gift i'm gonna give
you a uh your subscription to ramsay
plus visa dave fam and hook you up okay
and here's what's gonna do for y'all
this is gonna be a way it's gonna be a
tool that y'all can use obviously it's
get out of debt and all that kind of
stuff it's got all the
the app and all the stuff but more than
that it's a
it's a conversation starter for two
people who are learning to be on the
same page together
and some people are married for 20 years
before they figure out how to get on the
same page and they got four kids and
they realize we're in a mess and then
some people like you are like let's do
this on the front end
and so as you say i think i'm going to
transition to something else
i'm going to get out of something that
is highly regimented that's run pretty
much every minute of my life for the
last almost decade
that's terrifying i'm gonna start
something completely new i'm gonna do it
with this guy oh this guy does he have
tattoos everywhere
he does not oh he doesn't get him some
come on i'm just kidding
um i'm gonna this non-tattooed up guy
who's probably wonderful he's an
extraordinary guy i'm we're going to
start practicing this stuff together and
we're going to have some conversations
about hey how do you do money how did
you grow up with money how do you grow
up what do you think the role of a
military wife is or military are we
going to move for my we're going to do
it's going to give you all a a runway to
what could be a lifelong awesome
marriage
thank you so much for giving up
everything so my family can
put her around and do our life i'm
grateful for you alicia thank you so
much and thanks to that boyfriend of
yours he must be something special if
you're gonna give that up
and
um
always remember this there's a there's a
there's a map back if you go out into
the unknown and you realize you made a
big mistake there's a map back okay
this isn't an all or nothing situation
cool
cool i'm grateful for you good luck have
fun let me know when you when you put in
your resignation and you say hey i'm a
year out
um
and he proposes will you let me know
i will ah so cool you're the best